It's Tequila Sunsets's got it right. It is serious. They are
fighting, but basically the the bar on whether the bar on whether
or not it's content is whether or not they keep the stream on.
Everybody could easily go, "Oh, well, we're fighting. We're going
to shut the stream off." Right. You could do that. He's been
below 300 viewers for a bit. She needs the boost. Um, will this
even boost them? I don't know.
Are we on the same page now? >> All right. I'll put a sweatshirt
on. >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Never for me. No,
no, no. I'm just telling you
how I feel.
>> You can do wherever the you wanting
ever say. I I need you to swear you're not going to put words
in my mouth like that ever again. And that's not even the bad
one. The bad one. No, no, no. The earlier one when you said you
told me to dress that is putting words in my mouth because to
everyone else in the world that sounds like can you dress better?
Can you dress more revealing? That's what it sounds like. I never
said I I have never said that. Why are youing pretending like
I've said something and then you're saying well you said this
other thing which means this to me which means that it's like
what the dude it's triple what is it three degrees of separation
this word is close to this word is >> I don't I don't even
know what he's saying there but cool
triple triple three degrees of of separation
okay anyway there's like a whole they've got like a longer argument
that goes on here but apparently
you know this is some of the stuff so I I'm thinking about checking
it Oh, we've definitely got a little bit of stuff, a little bit
of a ways to go through it here. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
This is 1943.
>> Why did you get into this? Okay, >> that idea
out there that I asked you to dress sexy, you know, that's never
>> my feelings at all. >> No, no, no, no, no. You're
not good.
>> So, this is over basically Nick commented on how she
was dressed or something and
yeah, I know. I know this is like maybe think of Yms. This was
like Was this like a Is this like a furry costume here? I think
it's just supposed to be a horse. Okay.
>> You said you said you said that. I said that. I did
not admit that.
>> You can't just say I said something I didn't say. >> A
metric and we must we must appease the Sims on S forms cuz now
they're talking about your body.
>> No. If you think about that, dude, there's a two way
that can go. One is that you don't dress revealing to where it's
obvious. The second like is that you do it that way. I did not
tell you to do it that way. You did it that way. But you're sitting
here blaming me for
>> Bro, I never asked your dress in this whole time. 22
now. You say that. It's never been true. >> You complain.
>> No. No. Can you Can you just answer that so I know that
you're doing my animals and I don't have confessions.
>> That's not even true. >> That's what you did.
Yes.
Not high enough. We need more. We need more.
>> I don't know how to get like that. >> Is this
like when yesterday? Is this like when yesterday you said that
you wanted to do couples therapy, but I didn't? Is that Is that
the lie? Same >> What are you talking about? >> Did
you not remember last night when you said, "Oh, I wanted to do
couples therapy. You didn't." It's like, bro, that's the opposite.
>> Oh, you want more conversions? We need more conversions.
>> Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey. Conversions
don't just mean from stream, buddy. You realize have many other
platforms.
>> Uh, literally we were talking about Twitter and so let's
just [__] keep it on that subject because you keep
saying you you don't have the right >> this is the part
where
I I'm sorry if it were like an act it wouldn't come out so smooth
so smoothly right for them. That's why like I know Nick talks
when Nick is talking by himself this is like the stuff he talks
about that he's interested in. It's not like he wouldn't be perfectly
connecting it to his interest while he's angry in the moment.
Like it's just not it's not the same. >> You say you are
implying this because there's the only thing that it can mean.
When I literally had when I got you on the phone, the only thing
I talked about was Twitter. I didn't talk about how you're dressing
on stream. I didn't talk about conversions on stream. >> Stop
complaining about my appearance. >> No one's complaining.
>> You are. You are complaining. >> Okay, fine. Word
for word. What did I
>> Put your ass. >> No, no, no, no, no. Word for
word. As close as you can remember. Tip form is saying all this
stuff about you and uh you know it's about your appearance on
stream but that's you complaining about it. Say we need to optimize
for that. >> Okay. So my actual thing which is I actually
brought up yesterday. Wait, there's no way. There's no possible
way that Nick's going and reading like hater forums saying like,
"Oh, Amaran's like not attractive or something or she's like
not" and then he's like, "Oh, you need to dress more attractively
on stream based on like
what? Like the people who hate her like or it's not even that.
What would it be?" I guess for Twitter posts you need to like
dude, I don't even know. I don't even know what's going on here.
I'm having a hard time understanding what he's saying. Let's
optimize. We need more conversions. >> Was that >> dude?
Okay. It's like we need more conversions. I Is he doing And we'll
see. We'll listen more. But is he doing something where it's
like, "Hey, these people are complaining about like how you look
on stream or something and we need more conversions." Is he doing
everything like walking her to the line so that she can do it
herself?
Like so that she will dress more provocatively or something herself?
Is that Is that what he's doing?
Cuz cuz that sounds like that could be what this is is like he's
basically saying like, "Oh, these people are complaining that
you aren't attractive enough on stream and I need more we need
more conversions, so I'm going to let you." It's like, "Bro,
come on, man. You know what you're doing." >> Maybe all
it is is working on your posture or not wearing clothing that
makes it look that way.
None of that. Those are fixes that don't require changing anything
about your body. You should have better posture. You shouldn't
be.
>> I just opened something. God damn it. Oh, somebody gave
me somebody gave me this music. I don't know if you thought this
was appropriate or something.
>> You shouldn't be slouched like that anyways. The chair
that you have I mean I guess your paint on a different chair.
I don't like like none of that has any >> I have to slouch
to >> Okay. Okay. Okay.
The point is you were putting tremendous amounts of words in
my mouth. Okay. I never said anything about your appearance.
I certainly have never asked you to dress more.
Do not say I said that when you were implying that I must mean
that because this other thing I said which I gave a better example
for. I literally said conversions are low and then I gave Twitter
recommendations that in >> do more egirl stuff. >> I'm
saying what do you have?
It is actually the same thing. She's she's hearing like, "Okay,
there's one way we've like had conversions in the past. This
is what you built your fan base." She's hearing what he wants
to say but won't say. And then he's going, "No, no, no. I didn't
say that. >> You're being ridiculous. I brought conversions
below." And then I brought up Twitter mis and then finishes
>> and then you, you know, started complaining about that.
And so then what can I do except list other options?
No, for months you've been like, "We need more ego stuff. More
ego stuff. More ego
>> How many times have I said it? Like I said, maybe if
you don't have any ideas for an event or anything, you should
consider doing something that is a hook.
>> that's a suggestion that I I didn't say you got to do
this. That is a suggestion. You thought it was a good >> It's
what you want and now you don't. >> No, no, no, no, no.
you. Okay. First of all, when you say it's what I want, I gave
you multiple options to pursue. Okay. You pick, I guess, the
easiest one. I don't know. But are they so sensitive around this?
Well, what happens is like,
okay, what happens is like Amaranth basically says what she thinks
Nick is saying, right? She does some translation and Nick goes,
"No, no, no. That's not what I'm saying." And then Nick
like he won't do any work to like move forward with that. Like
he won't um basically if he thinks she's misrepresenting him,
he like has this like OCD thing kind of like it's it's very similar
in my opinion to like the Adavore thing where until Amaranth
agrees with like how he feels, they they can't move forward in
the conversation at all. There's like no give and take, right?
So, I think there are there have been cases where I think Nick's
probably been like a little bit correct, but he's been like so
overly pedantic about it and like while they're on stream is
the music super loud. I was trying to get it at the right level.
I need to find a better way to level the music with stuff, but
um so it's like it's Yeah, he gets so so pedantic about things
that there's just no way they could come to a resolution
and like they obviously need to figure out a way to
to communicate, right? That's the that's the problem. They just
need to find a way to communicate with each other. >> Can't
come back to me and say I am saying X Y and Z. >> Oh, also
uh the title, if you notice, is unpacking my therapy session
I just had. So, I don't know if they just they might have just
come back from therapy or something. Like they're they're doing
couples therapy before. So, it's not promising for them that
they they're having this kind of >> not giving me options.
I'm getting more ego stuff. >> I literally
>> So, what now? Are you [__] Are you [__]
kidding? >> Are you [__] kidding me? >> Are
you [__] kidding me? Are you [__] dude?
Like Like
do you just not hear anything except the the the the [__]
narrative that you want to push? Like yesterday alone, okay,
you said that I didn't want to do couple therapy. That is literally
the opposite of the truth. I wanted to do couples. You wanted
us to do singles. And then you [__] don't do it.
And then you [__] miss your [__] >> They've
got like a lot of money. Why? The bottleneck for almost everybody
for like therapy is like money. They've got all the money in
the world. How are they like this just could do all of it? You
could just do all of it. You literally have You guys are retired
essentially. You've got all the time. All you have to work on
is like fixing your relationship dynamic and like trying to be
happy. That's all you have to work on. I understand he wants
to like push forward in the in the work stuff, but like he doesn't
have the monetary bottlenecks that most people have to like try
to pursue, you know, fixing themselves in some way, trying to
pursue long-term happiness. He's got none of that. Like money
is usually the biggest thing preventing that for people.
And and they could easily just be doing this.
I don't know,
man. I
I don't know. I feel like you could talk to Nick and make him
understand this. The way they stream, I think the way both of
them stream,
this is like the least efficient way. You guys are slamming your
head into a wall and hoping the wall breaks for you. Like that's
what you guys are actually doing right now. You You should not
stream this much. Even if you want to stream like 24 hours, you
want to make it about your life, you can absolutely cut this
down to like 12 hours and just be more intentful about it. You
don't have to stream every down moment. You guys could talk off
stream, right? like doing these 24-hour streams like this, I
don't think it's effective at all for like for be for one for
like going viral, building like any kind of content at all. These
guys built a empire. Well, they did at a different time, but
like they they do have some moments where they could be like
funny content, but they're they're like just ramming their heads
against the wall like wondering why they're not getting good
conversion rates or something. It's like you guys aren't intentful
at all in your approach. Not even a little bit. Like I that's
like a concern I have for myself, for my own stream is like,
oh, I should probably spend more time thinking of like different
ways to break a mold or to make changes that could drive like
some sort of explosive growth, right? And streaming 8 hours a
day, maybe I need to take two or three of those hours and put
them into something else. I can't imagine you're doing 24-hour
streams that you have any time to work on anything that might
be like exciting or building towards some better anything. Like
I I don't even know. Yeah, I I have no idea. And he he must understand
that, right? Like he's a tech guy. He must understand that concept
that like there's diminishing returns on how many hours you spend
streaming. But he just doesn't I don't know this they're doing
this thing that's like
I don't I don't think there's any way they could be happy together
and both stream like 24 hours in a row like 120 hours in a week
or whatever they're doing. Like it's probably it's probably just
way too much. PTSD st too, which is probably why the flare happened.
And now you're denying that that has anything to do with it,
which is like crazy because you are sitting there citing my therapy
as if it's the factor. And then when >> I'm not citing
it that way. >> Fine. Fine. The point is though, I You
literally accuse me of not going and it's not that. It's you
that vetoed, not me. You can't just say the opposite of what's
true and keep rolling. I've never asked you. You trying to You
always do this defending thing where you say, "Oh, but you ask
me to wear a sexy clothing." What the are you talking about?
>> You ask me to do more ego stuff.
>> Bro, bro, >> hold on. Hold on. Before we go to
that, I was just going to show I pulled up Nick 300 hours almost,
right? 30 days active. Uh 289 hours a day in the month. Almost
9 hours and 38 minutes a day. Okay. Oh, and then the amaranth
one is right here. Let me reload this. 256 hours about 9 hours
and 30 minutes a day. Like that's like crazy crazy crazy amounts
of stream.
And I understand that you could like make money off of that.
And like for most people, Amaran's probably at 217 average viewers.
She's probably making enough money for most people that you're
like making a good living off of this. But I don't think I don't
think you could possibly be happy. And shouldn't that be what
they optimize for? Like how much money how much more money could
you possibly need?
Like just focus on being happy. You guys are like 30. You're
30. You're You're like You've got at least what? $50 million
in the bank. Uh in terms of
bro. You gota She's paid by the hour. No, no, no, no, no. She's
not paid by the hour anymore. Um Maximus, I think her her kick
contract ended as far as I know. I think that ended in July.
Isn't that like 80 before the multiplier? Uh it might be. No,
no, no. It's Sorry, it's not. Uh the multiplier on kick is like
1 and a half. It's not It's not like two, three, four. It's like
one and a half on kick. Or at least that's what I noticed um
going back and forth between YouTube. And I think if I'm if I'm
not mistaken, I think they've actually reduced that multiplier
down even more. I think it's bordering on not having a multiplier
anymore from what I understand.
Um and I assume that's because as they've expanded the KP thing,
an easy way to to reduce KPPP payments is just to get rid of
the multiplier, right? Yeah. Anyway, we continue. Uh, not with
this though. This This guy >> I've never asked you. You
trying to You always do this defending thing where you say, "Oh,
but you asked me to wear clothing." What the are you talking
>> You ask me to do more ego stuff and make
hold on hold on.
Do you not understand
that? like me saying
so first of all are we talking about the >> like I don't
understand how well I do I can understand it to some extent like
you're you're like emotionally disregulated right so you're you're
like losing it kind of but I just don't understand how your primary
for like hours on end way of interjecting in a fight is just
to scream until your your partner stops talking like just screaming
at the like just br like you're just going to keep doing that
until they stop and you get your word. That seems crazy. >> Most
recent conversation or later or earlier conversations just so
we're on the same page. I don't want you flip-fpping. Which one
are we talking about first?
>> Both cuz we mentioned it. >> No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. The sequence is different. Don't [__]
try that. Which one are we talking about? Why would you not want
to define what we're talking about? >> I'm telling you
both that we talked about it in our last conversation. >> Why
would we talk about both when Okay. So So here's the problem.
I'm talking about both. I talk about one, you're going to talk
about the other. And so I'll talk about the other talk about
like
let's keep it on the same subject so that there is no he said
she said so that way I'm not saying you didn't say that because
we're at least talking >> on the phone you said we need
more egirl content. Yes. >> Okay. So on the phone you said
you need more egirl content. Also Rodmus asks does he do coke?
I don't know if he does coke.
He said she said sure. I don't know if he does coke but obviously
both of them do something to be able to stream like these long
marathons, right? Like I don't think you do 24ish hour marathons
consistently without without coke or like some kind of aderall
or
Is this a new thing? This is a new thing. Dur 4K Gromil.
This is a new thing. Dat Gromil. Yeah, this is a this is brand
new. This is from yesterday.
>> Yeah, but that was after I mentioned the Twitter initiative
stuff and you were really [__] negative.
And so here's the thing, right? I didn't start there. I started
with other things that I thought were even better than >> No,
you started with the You started >> No way. >> You
started. >> You're going to try. Okay, fine. You're saying
I started the conversation with saying you got to do more ego
stuff. That's not >> Oh, okay. No, no, no. So, you're So,
you're So, you're admitting then that I did start the conversation
about >> Yeah. You're >> okay then? So, then that's
not even the first thing I said. It was after you were very,
very negative. I could tell your voice was rising, everything
that I was like, "Okay, well, I'll switch to another option then."
Like, like you cannot get mad at me for switching away from something
that angers you and then like like I'm just going down the list
of things that we could do.
You cannot sit there and tell me that I must be pining for an
outcome because it's like the third option I listed. That's >> Don't
It's not the first time you mention egos. Like you always say
we >> again. You talked about this instance. Let's stay
on this. We can go to the other instances later. this instance.
It was not what I was suggesting. It was literally my backup
because you were freaking out. >> It was not a backup if
you keep saying it multiple times. >> Bro, we're talking
about this conversation. Please stop. >> But it's not a
backup. It's something you still want to happen.
Listen, that's not true because I gave you the counter option
of or we could do none of this. Just tell me that you're not
wanting to put in the effort. It's all there for you so that
I know the road map for it. So I know the road map for it.
Which is crazy that I have to extract it from you in this way,
right?
>> Like it's crazy that I have to extract it from you in
this way. You can't just tell me. >> I don't have a road
map. I'm not no stop. It's just as simple as do you want to improve
these things and are you willing to do these things? If not,
fine. But that's why we're having the conversation. And and you
see, you get upset for me and you say like, "Oh, you tweeted
the [__] crypto thing." Bro, I drafted that tweet.
I gave it to you for approval. Your approval. I don't know what
you want from me here. Okay. But but like >> Oh, that's
that's so rough that they're still arguing over basically what
what led to the burglary happening or Yeah. the burglary happening
earlier this year, right? Like that's that's where they're going.
That's like really not good. That's not good at all. All right.
Like I'm sorry. This this shouldn't be something that you're
still repeatedly like bringing up in arguments 6 months, 8 months,
10 months later. >> If that's how you want things, well
then you see how that works. I still have to draft things. I
still have to come up with here are some options. You cannot
then turn it around and say these options are what you want to
do. It's like okay. So if we're just going to start with you
don't want to do anything, let's start there. Like you can tell
me that that's an option. I even ask that question. I go do you
even want to do this career? That's a question. If you say yes
and then I give you options that we can pursue, that's crazy
that you're then saying it's my narrative. You realize what's
happening, right? I ask you what you want. You say you don't
know, so I give options and then you get mad at me,
>> dude. All I'm doing is giving a person who says they
don't know, probably hasn't thought about it. Some weigh in because
I need to know. Do you understand that? >> Yes, you need
to know.
>> So So then why do you keep painting it? Why would you
just say like you just did that I asked you to dress? That is
not true. That's not true in 22. That's not true now. Why would
you say that? >> If you want more ego content so we can
get more conversion. >> I didn't say I wanted more ego
content. That was a later option. >> No, you've said it
multiple times, not just yesterday. So it's an existing desire
that you think it works. So now >> Okay. So stop right
there. So it's not that I want it. is that I'm pointing out that
these are effective things I've done in the past.
>> Like I don't know, man. The arguments they have just
are always the exact same. That's what gets weird to me is I
don't understand Dobby's not free. Well, Dobby's kind of free.
It seems like she doesn't do very much eirl content, but if you
don't want to do the egirl content at all, I don't know why you
wouldn't just put more effort into
like honestly both of them. I don't know why they wouldn't put
more effort into like the content they want to do. It doesn't
seem like they prep a ton. It seems like they kind of just like
live like a couch potato life in front of a screen,
right? Like there's not really a focus. There's not really there's
not really a focus. There's not really a niche that they're seeking.
They just kind of like don't they just do whatever they want
for hours a day. >> Okay. Thank you very much. Yeah,
that is the point. >> But now you don't want me to to dress.
Bro, I don't want you dressed like that when there's just staff
around. That's that's that's that. Yeah, cuz there's no reason.
You're not even streaming right now. Why the [__]
would you do that? >> Cuz I'm about to go stream, >> bro.
Then put it on when you go stream.
>> Like, you see, it's >> Am I allowed to walk over
here? >> Are you allowed? Are you allowed? Are you allowed?
>> Are you allowed, bro? >> Am I supposed to put
on a robe to walk through my house? >> Bro, bro, bro, are
you allowed? Are you framing it that way? Why? When have you
ever asked me for anything permission >> Now you're Now
you're selling. So,
so it sounds like
I can I can hear exactly what Nick is what Nick's real problem
is. Oh, so you'll dress like a for the help around the house,
but you won't dress like a string to make us millions of dollars.
I see how it is. I see what it is. Right. I feel like that's
in his head. What's going on is is oh, you'll dress you'll dress
like around the house with with the
landscapers, but you won't dress for us to make money. What is
that about?
telling you that I can't >> Bro, you realize that I walk
in there and you're standing over someone with your [__]
right. Like you realize
No, no, no, no. >> Is that right? Like >> you're
not out at all. >> Uh I saw a tremendous amount of side
boob and there's no >> um um actually I believe I shot
at least 40% of your breast material via a via a horizontal view
on you. Okay. I think there was a lot of side boob there and
and it's really not even debatable. >> So I don't there's
not even a [__] the normal suction thing. I don't
know why.
Can you see how that's ridiculous? You want me to [__]
walk around with my crotch imprinted everywhere? Would that be
appropriate? Would it would it be appropriate if someone who
works for us who is a girl dressed like you? Okay,
listen. You can do whatever you want. It is your house. I'm just
saying it makes me uncomfortable when you do that. Okay, that's
all that I'm saying.
>> Am I not allowed to express that or >> Sure. Note
it. >> Like, and and I I hate it when you throw in my face
that I tell you to dress like that cuz that's insane. I've never
in my life told you how to dress. Are you kidding me? I don't
know anything about women's clothing. I don't pretend to know
and I don't pretend to weigh in. >> No, you want ego stuff.
>> No. You see, but you are taking it to mean this specific
thing, which I never said.
Egro stuff to me is not how you're dressed, per se. That's mostly
being an eagirl though. >> No, it's not. No, it's not.
No, it's not. Dude, I don't think you get it, man. If you look
at it historically, being an egirl,
all those factors are there. Do people find you attractive? Yes.
Or do people find you appealing? Sure. But it's never been the
thing that made eagles pop. It's always controversy surrounding
something, right? >> Uh, no. I don't think so. I mean,
the controversy certainly helps, but I don't think it's just
controversy. I I don't I really don't think so, man. They're
adult kids. Yes, they cannot They cannot talk through anything.
They They do not have like any world experience. Like, it seems
like Nick, you know, had a job before or something, but now I
don't know, man. I It just doesn't seem like they've worked on
themselves or maturing over the past like year when they've had
all the time in the world to do it. And it it it's just very
weird to me. and they've had all the incentive in the world to
do it because they they're doing content like IRL content together.
I don't know why they haven't like figured some [__]
out at this point. >> And so, like I said, if there's controversy
happening on Twitter, if you can insert yourself, that counts.
>> Now, can I finish? Can I? I'm listing examples. You're
tacking the examples at number one because I didn't include another
example. Please, it it's about I can't know what you want me
to say first, second, third. I can only say all the things. >> That's
just a creator. That's not ego >> What's up, Cy? >> Right.
But that is how you court the
>> No, it's not. >> Getting impressions is not how
you court conversion. What? What? What? What? How do you What
do you think conversion stands for? It stands for how many people
do something before someone goes and buys on the way. Right.
So then if
>> No, a conversion is when somebody goes from being like
a passive intake on your like content to like doing something.
any any purchase, any direct like like buying a sub, that would
be like a conversion, right? Uh you could even say converting
to like chatter, right? How many people follow to how many people
chat? Like you could say that's a conversion,
but it's not
how you conversion. What? What? What? How do you What do you
think conversion stands for? It stands for how many people do
something before someone goes and buys on order, right? So >> Oh,
so he's talking about Hold on. He's talking about conversion
rate. Oh, he's talking about the conversion rate. That's what
he Okay. Okay. If you get more people to view, is it not upping
>> You have to have the eagle.
>> No, no. It's you're upping the number of conversions.
But like a conversion is somebody going to the next I I guess
you could call it conversion going from one stage of a funnel
to another, right? That would be a conversion rate, right? How
many people go from the first stage to the second stage to that
would be like conver you could simplify it, but I'd say at any
step of like a funnel, there's some there's some drop off, right?
And the conversion rate is how many people get through that part
of the >> part there like brew wise lookwise in order for
it to them to convert. Otherwise they're just see >> wait
what the [__] was that? Was that on here is it not
>> you have to have the eagle part there like brew wise
lookwise in order for it to them to convert.
>> What the was that? >> Otherwise they're just seeing
>> bro bro that's you taking that as the implication for
me. Okay, first of all, >> I have never asked you what
to do
to look more appealing in a piece of content for conversion.
That has never happened. I've only ever asked you to increase
the rate of eyeballs that see a thing. That is true because my
thing has always eyeballs that increase the exposure and the
rest of it will follow. >> You literally tell me you want
my appearance optimized. That's why >> No, I didn't. I
said I said it makes sense for us to be aware of like a like
if you don't count macros how the [__] you go like
literally literally we went to the >> Oh hold on hold on
hold on that's a big one right there. I said it makes sense for
us to be aware of like a like if you don't count macros, how
the [__] do you >> This is This is the thing.
Okay, I think this is the big one is basically Nick is always
trying to make sure Amaranth doesn't get fat and he refuses to
acknowledge that that's what he's doing. He He will always like
try to reframe it as like, "No, I just want to make sure you're
healthy or whatever." It's like I
and that's like
you could obviously argue that hey I don't want this like I I
think this would be bad for you but he he's always like no no
no I'm not like trying to account this he always like tries to
reframe how he's doing it and if he just like lean and go like
yeah I think it's important that you stay attractive. I I feel
like you just get rid of a whole bunch of this stuff. Just realize
those are horse stuffed animals. This is now scary. Yes, they're
all horses. Thank god that they're stuffed animals. Okay,
this is basically
Listen, little do they
this is just another version of the crypto tweet. Okay, YMS is
planning his his
YMS is planning his route into and out of this house as we speak.
Okay, he's studying all
all of the entrance the egresses and ingresses. Okay, so he can
make his way in and out without being caught. He's going to he's
going to own a bunch of these soon. All right. >> You go
like literally literally we went to the doctors and you got the
>> Wait, those are copies of her horses. So like she got
pictures of her horses and then made direct copies of the horses
she owns as stuffed animals.
That's cool. >> Yeah. When you go, "Oh, I didn't realize
I was this heavy." It's like, "What the dude?" Like now you're
going to say it's my [__] >> I said anything.
Jeez, >> bro. The fact is you don't know. So you when you
say I know exactly what I weigh. It's like Well, you just didn't.
So then what the [__] are you saying? Look,
it's the same thing, right? Do I know we have enough money? Yes.
But then why do I keep track of the number? Um because that's
just smart.
Why wouldn't you want information when you can have it? Why would
you choose to not have it? Do you understand that? Why would
you choose to not have information when it's available? Huh?
>> Well, so the answer I I know the answer is cuz she feels
like you're really controlling over her, right? Like she feels
like you've basically forced her to do this only fans thing her
whole career. And so probably like you tracking her macros feels
like another way of controlling her. She probably doesn't like
that. She probably very she probably bristles at that very significantly,
right?
Like that's that's what's going on here very obviously. She doesn't
like the feeling that Nick controls her. And
I guess he's like, "No, no, no. I would never do that." And he's
saying, "No, no, we should but we should also track your macros
because you you told me, oh, like I don't know how I'm I'm weighing
so much more or some, right? And we don't track your macros."
I understand where he's coming from. He's like, "Well, obviously,
you know, if you don't track what you eat, you don't work out
very much. You're going to get fat." That's like obvious. I understand
what he's saying, but
if she doesn't want to do that, I don't know. There's ultimately
not a lot you can do.
She's she's an adult. She's basically retired. If she wants to
spend her retirement getting fat, that's her prerogative, I guess.
>> You you you want so badly to vilify, and if you feel
that way, then still get a divorce, man. Oh, also real quick
guys, if you're watching on Twitch,
uh we're ending the Twitch portion of the stream. So go ahead,
head over to
That's kick.com/jstlk.
We're going to do the rest of the stream on kick. Thank you very
much for all the Twitch viewership we had for this whole stream.
All right, appreciate you guys. And we're going to be live over
on Kick. I mean, we are live there now, but we will stay live
on Kick. We're going to end the Twitch portion of the stream.
Thank you very much for watching, guys. I'll be back later. Bye.
Okay, we end the Twitch portion of the stream. We go kick only
and we're going to continue. >> Like like I I don't understand
this. You sit here and you say I asked you to dress. So why am
I complaining? Are you kidding me? >> When did I say that?
>> When you were saying do egro stuff. >> You can't
just say this other word means this other word means this other
word to me. Do you not understand that? >> That is part
of being negro. That is the >> I don't care. I'm not asking
for it.
>> you have so
mad narrative that it must be I'm saying this because that's
the only possible thing I can mean. Is that what you're saying?
>> What do you think e being eirl is then,
Literally, it is. I don't know the meta push. I'm telling you
that right now. To me, being uh doing ASMR is egirl stuff, right?
To me, doing body painting is zero stuff. To me, doing a pool
or a hot tub stream is zero stuff. See how those are related
around actions? No one is saying do more egirl stuff as a way
of saying dress more ain't ever happened. That's so lowbrow and
it doesn't work for very long. It's not even a good solution.
I don't know where you are getting the idea. That's the only
thing it can mean when in history and in our usage of the term
it's only meant not
>> doing a pull string is more like like >> it's
not it's not it's not poking through like that. No, it's not.
It's not that much side boob usually. No, it's not. But also,
>> wait. Like, yeah, hold on. What is his argument? I thought
he was like, "Oh, I don't necessarily want you to dress, but
like you could do hot tub streams or you could do body painting
streams. You could do ASMR like really sexual." What is he doing,
dude? What?
I don't understand what he's trying to say. How can he not see
how bad that is? I'm not saying you have to do like things just
like you know do all the softcore versions of streaming maybe
>> there's a contextual appropriation of the fact that
if you're in a pool it's a different thing okay don't don't don't
sit here and [__] semantics with me the point is
is I'll ask again if a female employee dressed like that would
you be okay with it that's why that's all I need to know >> but
I'm not >> okay then no I I realize that I realize that
but I was telling you my opinion which is that it makes me uncomfortable
when you do that okay Let's Let's be honest here. You have had
some boundary issues, huh? With the [__] yoga instructor.
Like, let's be honest here. Like, I don't know if you want to
be pushing boundaries, >> dude. Do you guys remember we
we watched that, right? We watched the yoga instructor like stretching
Amaranth out. Uh, not in the way you think. Okay. The guy was
like pushing her down for yoga. And Nick just sat there watching
like the most the worst still frame from like like the worst
possible looking still frame from that entire stream. We watch
him like rant in front of it for like 45 minutes. It's still
sitting there like taking up all of this real estate in his
>> Real estate page. >> Uh was it like Couples retreat?
Maybe. I don't know if I've seen that movie. It was like basically
one of their employees also was a yoga yoga
Oh man, maybe I can find it. Somebody somebody can try to find
it. But he was just like so mad and he was like his chat was
sending him the screenshots of it, right? sending the screenshots
of it and he was just seething about it like how he was so betrayed.
Uh it's it was just crazy. Okay, it was the height of the Usuzbck
era when he had all these Russian people who used to watch Amaranth
and they just kept calling him anc
all the time. Now I feel like he actually gets real viewers.
It's not the same. But it was the height of the Usuzbck cuck
era. We miss it. >> All right, I'll put a sweater on. >> No,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Never for me. No, no, no. I'm just telling
you
how I feel.
You can do where the you want.
>> Uh I believe so.
Dude, no. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. Okay. Uh so I don't think it was a landscaper sweatpants
freedom. I think it was their dog babysitter, the guy who was
taking care of all their animals at the house. Because I think
when they fired him, now Amaranth had to take care of all the
animals. She had to clean up after her rabbits and her dogs and
all of this other [__] I think so. >> Do not
[__] >> But he also had a yoga certification
or >> [__] swear you're not going to put words
in my mouth like that ever again. And that's not even the bad
one. >> The bad one. No, no, no. The earlier one you said
you told me to dress that is putting words in my mouth because
to everyone else in the world that sounds like can you dress
better? Can you dress more revealing? That's what it sounds like.
I never said I' I have never said that. Why are you pretending
like I said something and then you're saying well you said this
other thing which means this to me which means that it's like
what the dude it's triple what is it three degrees of separation
this word is close to this word is means that other word the
and the first jump is so arbitrary right you're like oh you gave
suggestions about what to do on Twitter and then you mention
you know >> dude I just have to say okay I'm I'm actually
I just got like triggered there just absolutely triggered by
the radial
radial alarm clock sound. Okay, they've got like an alarm going
off in the background for some time and I'm like I I I don't
know if I'm the only one traumatized by it. I can't possibly
be like you hit snooze and then the radio alarm comes back on.
You don't want to get up. I I can't be the only one >> when
you got in since that like or or we could do ego stuff and so
ego stuff means dressing more revealing. It's like the [__]
where did that come from? When has that ever meant that? It has
never meant that. No, you have always pretended that's narrative.
When I say conversion every time I'm talking not about rate,
I'm talking about aggregate amounts of
I'm growing the upper funnel.
You keep talking about what trickles through the lower funnel.
>> Okay. But like conversion is going from the upper funnel
to the lower funnel.
>> that is a misconception that you harbor. It's not one
that I hold.
I've never said, "Can you increase for a thousand viewers the
amount of people watching by dressing more?" I've never >> Oh,
well that's weird if you're talking about conversion cuz improving
conversions would be that would be exactly otherwise you're like,
"Oh, I'm going to increase leads." That would be a different
That would be a different word, man. That would be leads, dog.
>> Hold on. This is the couple's retreat scene apparently.
As somebody >> Please regard me. I'm sorry. Please allow
me to do what? Regard me. >> Okay. Yes.
You are doing fantastic my dear. >> Thank you. Okay. >> We
all know exactly where this is going. It was a little bit like
this. Okay. >> And bring it deeper and deeper into >> I
think it was nowhere near this inappropriate, but there was one
specific pose that somebody took a screenshot of and it sent
to Nick and he left up on his screen while he ranted. >> Okay.
Fabulous. >> Then do it. Yes. Encouragement, my >> Finally,
Ronnie and David. >> Yes. Yes.
>> Never imply any of those things. I've said we've got
it. >> It was It was a little I think he was trying to
get like hamstring stretching.
It was It was maybe I could see how somebody be like, "Ah, that
makes me uncomfortable." I I could understand that feeling. You
just never ever express that feeling in the world, right?
I
I think the one looked a little bit much. >> Increase the
conversion. Conversion being the people who funnel through and
the easiest way to convert people is to get more eyeballs.
That is the game. If you look at everything I say, it's in that
vein. Okay, think about it. When I say this tweet got 2 million,
you know, impressions, what the [__] does that mean?
It means that 2 million eyeballs saw it. Why is that the number
I'm talking about instead of how you dress it? Did I ever once
mention that?
See, how you can you say that when I talk about metrics and numbers,
it must mean I want you to dress. That is not true. That's a
chip on your shoulder that you're trying to pin on me.
No. Hey, can can I can you just answer the question? Did I actually
say those words or are you just >> am I I feel like he's
actually in the wrong here and I think he's almost noticed it
that he was talking about conversion. Yeah, you would want He's
literally talking about this precisely. He's not talking about
building up more leads. He's just talking if he's talking about
conversions then that is Yeah, you need to improve your ability
to convert somebody from like a passive viewer to some kind of
active viewer. >> Inferring. I gave you no reason to infer
that. You still infer it. >> Colin, you are giving a reason
to infer
>> What reason? >> Because you want people to be
so attracted to me that they go search for my only pants. In
order to do that, they have to be aroused. That is literally
arous. That is literally your interpretation of what it all must
mean. That's never what I've said. I I I invite you to say that
I'm lying here. I have never said it like that. And I've never
meant it like that because that's a dumb way to go about it.
>> How am I supposed to interpret what you're saying? It's
simple. It's simple. Okay. When you increase your
the clothing, the only thing that you're doing is you're you're
giving a short-term
spite to the people who are watching, right? >> It doesn't
it doesn't strategically set you up to be able to in any kind
of way
replicate that going forward. It's a short-term can I finish
a sentence. >> It's a short-term bump. No, nowhere in there.
I told you before. I literally gave the example. I said, "If
we can chain, you know, another eight to 10 of these tweets,
I said we could probably get it back to this other level." You
see how that is about impressions.
That is about topline impressions.
>> Yeah. Impression. Yes. Oh, now he's using the words
correctly. That's not what conversions are. That's >> That
is not about conversions in terms of maximizing
to get more people to click.
It's about maximizing more people seeing anything. But you just
said that there's a there's bump in viewers if I dress. So isn't
that >> I didn't say that. I didn't say that. >> You
just >> wait what? Wait, what?
We just heard him. He literally said there's a short-term bump
in your That's just short term. That's a short-term bump of yours.
Just helps the people. I She's like, "What? You just said it
this way." And he's like, "I did not just say it that way." What?
Hold on. >> That is about topline impressions. That is
not about conversions in terms of
to get more people to click.
It's about maximizing more people seeing people. >> But
you just said that there's a there's bump in viewers if I dress.
So isn't >> I didn't say that. I didn't say that. >> You
just >> Oh, no. No. No. I What? >> I just said it.
>> You did? Yes. >> In what sentence? >> Cuz
you told me that like when you dress that is a bump in eyeballs,
but it's >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I said it's
a bump in people clicking on your
>> That's a bump in eyeballs. What is he doing,
bro? He's got to realize how bad this looks to anybody on the
outside. I'm not saying more people are watching. I'm saying
more people are clicking on your stream to open the link. I'm
I'm not saying listen, it's just more people are clicking the
link to open your >> But that's what it all is. You're
trying to get more people. Okay, I won't try to explain one more
time for you because you're not very [__] smart.
I guess
what I'm saying is that is a short-term temporary increase. Do
you understand that it the long-term increase is learning how
to court controversy
and getting the eyeballs consistently? Do you not understand
that? What if you respond?
So, if I was going to try to listen, if I was going to try to
do the steelman or whatever, which is not really even steel manning
because Nick is not making his argument. What I think Nick is
trying to hint at is, okay, there's a way to build viewership
in a way that's costic and and temporary and doesn't get people
like enticed in in maintaining a relationship with you where
they chat or they donate or whatever where where if you're just
dressing, they could like come in and take a look and then they're
like, "Okay." And they move on, right? He's trying to describe
like retention almost. I think he's trying to describe retention
in some way and he's like he's changing his terms all over the
place. It seems like that's more what he's talking about. Building
something up long term and and hey, if you're going to keep having
these takes that are controversial, you will build up some kind
of retention as well, I think, is where he's going. >> That's
what I think sexier does. It gets more eyeballs. >> What
are you doing? What are you doing right now? What are you doing?
>> Can you Can you not keep walking, >> Cy? Uh, he
does not he does not comfort her when she cries. Okay, that I
think you need to know I think you need to know a little bit
more about these people. Okay, this guy when she cries that's
like him. He's like, "Oh, you're just trying to use emotion."
He's like Asminold in that moment. Okay, he's like Asminold in
that motion or in that moment. He's like, "Oh, you're just trying
to use my emotion against me to win the argument." Well, I'm
going to stay logical in this moment and say that you're still
wrong. That's that's actually where it goes. cuz he like gets
angrier when she starts crying. Oh, come on. Please start walking
back. >> Get over here. That that that telling you how
to do it. >> They do walk back. >> No, I giving you
any way in. >> Dude, you can you stop trying to be so black
and white. Like, I'm not telling you how to do it.
And if you want me to stop helping you, I'm more than happy to.
Can you get over here? That that that I don't know why you get
so close to the [__] door.
You keep trying to pin me on things, but I know your game. >> I
don't tell you how to do it. >> She's not even I swear
to God, she's not even being aggressive. She's like just saying,
"Well, I think you just said this." After he said the exact thing
she says, like, "Oh, he says like the exact statement." And then
she follows up with, "I think you just said this exact statement."
And he goes, "No, I didn't. No, I did not." And then he's like,
"I see your tactics. You're just trying to pin me down on something."
He's like, he's losing it. >> I don't tell you what to
do. All I do is ask you where you want to go. You see, I don't
know. And then I go, "Okay, well, do you want me to keep going?"
You go, "Yeah." And then I go, "Okay, well, here's some things
that you can do to help with that." That's all that happens,
man. That's literally all that happens now.
Isn't that true? I literally preface it by saying, "Do you even
want to do this?" I say that, don't I? Why can't you answer the
question? >> I want to do this. I don't want you to deform
my body. >> No, no, no. Stop. Stop. Simple. Stop. Stop.
So, you're saying that I do ask you whether you know you want
to do
>> Okay. Yeah. Cuz I always start that I start by saying,
"You sure you want to do this thing?" Cuz to me, it looks like
you don't really want to, right? And so, I am asking you, are
you sure you want to do this? If you say yes,
then I'm willing to help you,
but it seems like you're attacking
cuz I could just not do it. I could just [__] let
it drop by the wayside. Let's see how long it lasts.
You don't want that, I don't think. And if you do, great. Solves
my problem. You know you don't want that. You've never wanted
that. And then you attack me because I'm trying to help you.
And you try to pin the nitty-gritty of it on me. When I don't
give specifics, I literally give you very >> You're telling
me about some forums and what they think does not help me. I
don't care about them. All you're doing is making me function.
>> You were pushing that narrative before I even mentioned
it. Yes, >> dude. This is another reason they can't argue
on stream at all is cuz every single time she like makes a point,
he's like always thinking about the narratives and how they're
like received on the stream or whatever. Like
if if that's all you think because it's being broadcast, then
you aren't built for this. Not that I think anybody's built for
this. I think um doing this in public is like extremely I don't
know how you would do it. It's like rough, man. like having these
arguments on stream, but even if even if they were like healthier
in how they argued, but they're like so so dysfunctional in how
they argue. Mostly on Nick's side, almost entirely on Nick's
side, right? You might think that when not streaming, too, though.
Well, he does. He almost he's also he's the only one the one
streaming it. Okay, but I man I he's just always thinking about
he's always thinking of like how she's trying to paint him. I
don't even think that's fair anymore. He gets the same number
of viewers she does, right? He's not that far behind in viewership
anymore.
It's narrative you wanted to push. So you're pushing it. It's
not that you talking about >> you try to say that I criticized
your body yesterday when in actuality I said it makes sense to
track metrics so that we can you know figure out you know how
to troubleshoot right and I gave you a bunch of metrics like
can I finish the sentence? I gave you metrics like stream. I
gave you metrics like, you know, um the viewership, the retention,
and then we talked about how, you know, and also you should just
track your macros because you literally said you didn't realize
how heavy. >> I don't think it's it's not a >> I
am not criticizing. I'm just saying what you said. >> I'm
sorry I said anything. >> No, no, no. You got to be sorry.
Why? Why? Why are you saying you're sorry you said anything?
You okay? Do you not understand this? If you don't know how much
you weigh, that's fine. But you I mean I guess you can say whatever
the [__] you want, but when you say I know what my
metrics are, it's like well this doesn't happen. >> You're
saying clearly >> I don't care, Nick. I want you to stop
>> Oh, I know you don't care. So So then like why the [__]
So I just know that these doctors are putting >> I also
just have to wonder did she bring this up on stream or did he
cuz I feel like why the would you bring your wife who does this
who like works kind of as a model online. Why would you bring
up her insecurities on a live stream? Because that's what he's
doing, right? He's literally saying like, "Well, you did tell
me you thought you were getting fat." Bro, why would you ever
bring that up on a live stream? That's insane.
He brought it up. Okay, that's nuts to bring up. Again, this
is sort of like the we saw this happen with him a couple other
times, right? Where he was very like violative of her privacy
on the live stream. It's like a pattern that is clearly not abated.
It's clearly still going on. is very very very [__]
up actually, right? To put that out there for everybody else
to use. Like she's a live streamer. She's got a chat too that
could easily say to her that would make her feel uncomfortable
and you're going to put that out there for everybody to use against
her. It's that's nuts, man. >> With you and then I'm just
supposed to close my ears and not hear anything. Is that like
what the [__] am I there for then as a [__]
taxi driver?
>> Dude, like like >> you can be supportive. You
don't have to [__] any >> Okay, dude. Well,
when you tell me that you are surprised by something, I'm supposed
to just be like, "Oh, [__] that." Whatever, dude.
>> No, just
>> don't say anything. >> Oh, don't say anything.
Okay, thanks. So, why the [__] am I there? I don't
see. I don't hear. I don't >> about that topic. You don't
have to say anything about that. >> Okay, but but I'm asking
you this. If you surprised yourself, then would that not be
uh you out of
whack of what you thought it was? It is, right? I'm not asking
you to micromanage >> I'm not asking to micromanage it.
I'm
>> That's crazy, dude. That's like if I said, "Hey, you
know this thing." >> That's crazy, dude. >> I want
to be doing more or less of it. >> And then you brought
up, well, you said this thing
at all. >> It's like, dude, if I tell you I look easy.
If I tell you I know exactly how much Bitcoin,
>> and you go, how much? >> Okay, it's got to be
near the end here. We'll we'll keep listening for a little bit.
I'm ready to move. There's another section here where she comes
back and starts talking to him in chat. We might go to that in
just a little bit here. Imagine having a normal conversation
with your wife. She says, "I think I'm fat." Is such a normal
conversation. And then putting it out in public. Yeah, I know.
It's like
to me it's it's wild to go It's wild to go and do this because
for all the reasons I said before, for all the reasons that it
doesn't make sense for them to stream this much, for all the
reasons that it doesn't make sense that this is their content
strategy, these 24-hour streams, right? They have retirement
money. They could just focus on being happy. Neither of them
is focusing on being happy. And they're literally trying to like
destroy their own happiness for the sake of like to get to get
fame back. And Nick wasn't even famous in the first place. So,
it's I don't get it. It just doesn't make any sense. Man, >> guess
the wrong number. Well, then aren't you going to be like, well,
maybe you should, you know, look into that. Of course you are.
Cuz it's a discrepancy from what I just said, right? And so what
you just told me is a discrepancy from what you told me then.
And so like to me that's like well maybe you should look into
it. I'm not saying I want to. I'm saying maybe you should. And
I'm giving you the tools to do so by saying here's how you can
go. And I'm getting vilified. No. No. I said you can track your
own macros. I said I don't care what they are. You just need
to know. That's all I said. And I it became a witch hunt for
what I must be thinking. Dude, you gave me a piece of information.
You said this is higher than expected. I give you a way to track
it for the future. I'm the bad guy. >> I wasn't trying
to give you a piece of information. My mistake.
>> The point is not. >> Bro, this is like I feel
like this is something that you do figure out in your 20s in
relationships, like your early 20s is like, oh, sometimes somebody's
just venting to you. They're giving you like information without
a particular goal. They're like, oh, this made me feel bad. And
they're not saying like, help me solve this right now. They're
like, hey, I feel like this. And so the answer would be to like
to go, okay, that sucks. I still find you attractive. If you
wanted to work on it, let me know. If you just want to like
if you just want to like
know that I I'm not worried about it or that we'll work through
it, then there you go. You have your support from me. Okay? That's
all you need to do. That's like the thing,
Sometimes people will tell you something. It's not just women,
although I do think it happens manto woman more often, right?
A woman says, "Here's an emotional thing I'm feeling." And the
guy's like, "Well, here's how you'd fix
Right. But most people figured that out way earlier. I don't
know how Nick Nick still hasn't figured it out. It seems >> not
whether you meant to give it or not. The point is that whether
you intended to or not, you don't know what you are professing
to know. And I am merely saying that there is a way you can know
and then telling you what that is. You're treating that like
it's me calling you fat.
That's insane,
dude. That's insane. It's like if I told you, "Oh man, I'm coughing."
And you go, "Oh, you know, you should take COVID test."
Am I supposed to freak the [__] out of you? Like,
no, dude. You are literally hearing an input and then you're
giving your best way of how that can be figured out resolved.
Why are you treating it like when you said that and then I suggested
a thing, I'm the crazy person?
And like I don't know this weird sense of decorum you have about
how I can say this in this context in that context I can I just
believe that we should be able to talk to each other. Okay. Like
like I don't know why it is this weird.
It's like court entry. It's like there's a decorum for talking
to the queen. Bro,
I think like again
I think
it's just he's framing it adversarially, right? He's saying like,
"Oh, I can't say anything that makes you upset. I can't say anything
bad to you and and you're like the queen and I just have to be
I just have to make you happy." It's like, well, no, this your
wife. You should both be trying to make each other happy, right?
That's it. That's how it is, man. Or don't be married. I don't
know what to tell you. But that's like the solution is you're
in a relationship. You should both be trying to make each other
happy. If that's not the way you look at your problems, then
you're going to have trouble fixing any of them. >> How
do I talk to you and give you
Do I have to do some crazy ritual to where you're like, "Okay,
well, this none of this is me judging or doing anything. And
all of this is just information. Do I got to write it down on
a piece of paper and just give it to you like a report or what?
Like I'm very confused. You ask me to go to the doctor. Would
I go with you? You explain that you are weighing differently
than you thought. And then I suggest that you track your macros
because it's easy to figure out if your macros are consistent.
I don't want help with my weight. I'm not >> evil Johnny
Bravo. The peak incel comment. No, not that it's wrong. Just
not not that it's wrong. Just peak incel comment. Okay. I don't
think you could have any problem with this. Uh, the way I'm describing
this evil Johnny Bravo. Okay. Giving women solutions to their
problems is like locking a bird in a cage. Their contrived problems
give their lives meaning.
How about you chill, bro? Jesus Christ.
>> I'm not offering help. I'm offering you a way to track.
>> I know how to do that. >> There's two ultim Okay,
first of all,
ultimately there's two possibilities, right? It's either you're
eating something that you're not accounting for or it's a hormonal
thing. But you see, isn't it good to know if you're like, "Oh,
I'm consistent with my diet."
Then you know what it is. It it's it's just literally how you
through the process of elimination find the information that
you need. I don't know why you have turned it into a witch hunt
for me to >> Now it seems like it seems like you just said
you don't want help with this. You don't want me to help with
this at all. Okay. And what I'm going to tell you now is it could
be one of two problems causing your issue. All right. I don't
want your help with this, Nick. Well, what I was saying before
you cut me off, you stupid [__] was there's one of
two possibilities that are causing your >> Thinking that
that's insane. >> You just made it worse by bringing up
s forms. Now you are acting like I have an appearance issue.
>> No, no, no. You challenged me. You literally said I
didn't talk about s forms at all. >> No, no, you're right.
Okay. Can I say what you said?
or you not want me to. >> What did I say? >> You
literally said, "I don't see how this has anything to do with,
you know, >> simp forums." Uh, I do believe this is like
people who would I I'm guessing s forums are like uh something
like where you would discuss like either Twitch eirls, Twitter
eirls, e- girls from different platforms, right? Or like fan
fan forms kind of. I'm guessing sort of like a KF or something
maybe. I I would assume some of them would be negative, some
of them would be like positive. >> Know my appearance in
terms of literally me saying, "Look, for whatever reason, you
know, there's been a decline, right? There's less people talking
about stuff, right? And the things they are talking about are
negative." That's all that it >> So farms has always been
negative.
>> You for years told me they just cut my load days. >> I
think you are, >> bro. I do. I literally I literally think
based on like inferring from context purely I think they might
be talking about likeers. Yes. I think they're talking about
like some version of like sarking.
I'm not joking. I'm pretty sure
>> what the [__] I'm saying? I'm saying >> bro
is this a is this Listen, hypothetically, okay, if this does
exist, is there like is there money in like a YouTube video market
for this? Is could you be the turkey tom of like the version
of Kiwi Farms where you go through and you figure out all the
bad clips for certain egirls and you like make a thing? Is that
is that a is that a gold mine? A hidden gold mine that nobody
has yet excavated.
We might have we might have some thoughts going on here >> that
there is no positive news out there. Not on
not for anywhere. >> I don't get anything. >> Then
don't wait. Then don't I I'll give you then don't ask me why
it matters if you are going to not care about the answer just
don't ask when you go why does that matter it's like okay well
I can explain why oh no what the [__] you saying
that it's like
why do you ask me if you didn't then don't is there is rhetorical
or what do >> just tell me it's rhetorical man
>> I'm telling you my appearance has nothing to do with
the Twitter [__] that's what you're really focused
on >> I never said again who said that >> that's
what I was telling you. I said, "What?" My parents didn't have
anything to do with that. >> I I I I Okay, first of all,
I don't think you understand. It's that you were giving me I
I gave you two pieces of information. You started cutting me
off. You started digging in. I didn't get to say my opinion.
So, I switched to the next thing. Okay? Like, like I my first
thing was Twitter. You know, that's an easy way to do it, right?
My second thing was, you know, reacting to content. That's another
easy way to do it. when you jump down my throat for both of those
and you start raising your >> Like I the funny thing is
is I could just explain like for most people the bottleneck to
getting their content out there is money is resources, right?
And the funny thing is is this guy literally understands the
concept of using resources to get through those bottlenecks.
He understands it, but he doesn't advocate for like or or neither
of them do the thing that would actually push them forward, right?
Like I could tell you exactly the plan. The only plan they need
is one, okay, go hire some people who are going to clip your
stuff and post your stuff. Figure out what if you want to do
it the way he's doing it. Like he's like, "Oh, you should react
to things. You should have incendiary takes." Go rage bait on
Twitter. Get people to clip your go post your go message in DMs
and say like, "Hey," or or get somebody to like message O or
go to Ox Discord and drop your clips in there so that he cuts
them up and does things too. Like this would be you could easily
do this, right? Find out the the accounts where most people fearbuck
a o figure out how they farm their clips and go make sure your
clips end up in those places so they see them. Make sure they're
sufficiently like rage bay and you'll get more people going to
your
right? But he's like, "Oh, you should you should do like this
kind of it's not even like about the content really in my in
my opinion. You could do this over anything, but you guys spend
like 24 hours streaming not doing the things you could actually
do. I don't know. It's just it's bizarre to me that he he should
have every he should have every understanding of how to get this
done and he advocates for like the worst
>> and yelling at me. I don't know. Like it's not reacting
to videos. Reacting to videos isn't what gets you like viewers
having like a really good It's like you need to know what the
clip is that you're pulling from the reaction that people could
also react to. Right? That's the thing is you're you're going
to try to
uh how would you say you should have some idea of how you want
to react to things or what your take is on like an overall situation.
You see somebody be stupid and you get like really you go off
on them, you go off on their misunderstanding, you try to explain
something, you put it together in one little clip and then you
want people to like post that clip for you.
That should be how you do it. >> Like what am I supposed
to do? Just [__] give up or what?
I I I so I went, okay, well, let's go to the third topic. It's
not that crazy or dramatic, especially if you stop attributing
to malice anything that I [__] say because like I
said, if you think it's malice, I can just stop. I don't have
to touch anything. I don't >> So, I understand that I do
this uh Porter Beller, but I do this um and I think money is
sort of like a bottleneck for me or like the amount of money
I expect to be able to like try to bring home is a bottleneck.
I probably shouldn't look at it that way, but that's like a different
thing. Okay, that is like a a very different thing. And I don't
even have the stamina to go listen, I don't take like a a dose
of aderal that lets me work for this long. All right, if I if
I just had infinite money, I could like buy, you know, an insane
dose of empetamines and spend like 3 months on this. Maybe I'd
figure it out. Maybe I'd crack it. But I do actually I'm just
describing as well to you like what I would need to do. I I need
to like switch over to Twitter, okay, for for like bringing people
in. I understand that, right?
It's maybe maybe I'm not starting it as fast as I should. So
listen, it's going to happen to touch anything. I can just not
do it. You can handle it all. I'm more than happy for that. But
don't sit here and ask me to do stuff and then [__]
question the way that I do it. Okay? I'm willing to work with
you on a more amenable way. But you got to [__] communicate,
man.
And that has to start with you not telling me what I must be
saying that I didn't actually say. Are we on the same page there?
Like why do you do that? Is is it just like you It's like you're
vilifying me and you're making it look really bad on purpose,
right? Like like there's no reason cuz I didn't say those words.
You just said I did. And then you go, "Well, you meant them."
It's like, "So I didn't say them, but I meant them." And so it's
like, "Okay, so it's a whole another phrase that you're taking
to mean a thing that you mean to me another thing." And then
that's what it must be translated. Why? >> How it feels.
>> Bro, can I tell you something though? But like I >> that's
like got to be like okay if
I assume this is therapy 101 is like okay you could you could
be upset as Nick and say by the way Nick's wrong at a base level
Nick is wrong. Nick is not remembering like the conversation
from before very effectively at least whenever we watch the stream.
It seems like he has the the less reliable memory. his memory
gets more moderated by his emotions at any given point in time
to the point that he he talked about her assaulting him when
she kind of like barely blocked his path slightly with her arm
sticking out and didn't even do anything close to assault. Okay,
so he's already wrong on that base level. But even if he was
right here, you would still if you're married to this person,
if they're like, "Well, I feel that way." Right? You would still
want to talk through that. But he doesn't talk through that.
He's like, "No, stop doing that. Stop right now.
I've told you this multiple times. If you feel like how I'm saying
it is not wellreceived, can you tell me how to say what I'm trying
to say? Because I will then say that's not what I mean. Here's
what I mean. And then you'll still freak the out. It's like offer
me an alternative. Then all you're doing is trying to freeze
the communication and yell. Do you not understand that you need
to offer like if you don't want something expressed a certain
way, I'm more than happy to say it however you want me to say
it. But you're not giving that to me and you're telling me what
I must be saying whenever I talk. Let's just don't talk about
my appearance. Just leave that part alone. Like I don't understand
you giving feedback on social media stuff saying that we have
to when I suggest the drama stuff we have to do it quicker in
order to meet the stuff you explain with the whatever bigger
butt guy. I get that. You don't have to bring my appearance into
it. >> Oh, maybe Nick does understand a little better than
I expect. He's talking about >> I just feel like lately
you do this thing where when you are insecure about something,
instead of addressing it, you just stick your head. Like that's
what it feels like you do. Okay? And I'm not even just talking
about appearance at all. It goes way further back. Okay? Whether
you had the drug lupus, whether you had PTSD, everything is a
battle.
And you're making it harder for yourself to get the help you
need when you resist because you don't like the label it assigns
to when no one else signing that label. It's just you now.
>> Like when it comes to >> I'm going to try to go
to the next time stamp. I think this is uh this is starting to
slow down for me a little >> Not hitting the same. And
I've got some other stuff I want to do later. So,
>> okay. Um
let's see. I got another time stamp here. 2257.
Okay. So, after this
Nick comes back. Nick is streaming on his own and Amaranth enters
his chat and so he starts ranting at Amaranth in the chat. Okay.
Uh let's see. I'm going to pull these two chats up. I'm just
going to show them just in case we miss them as the stream happens.
But it was basically all I asked you was for you to not try to
manage my macros or body measurements. I said you wanted me to
get more
Okay. So, this is a little bit little bit more little bit later
on. She said I called her fat because when we were at the doctor's
appointment for her, she got on the scale and goes, "That's weird.
I don't remember being this heavy." And it's not that heavy.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Let's just be honest. The doctor's office scales everywhere in
North America are rigged because they want everybody in America
to be less fat. So like they add like 5 or 10 pounds automatically.
Everybody knows that. Everybody knows that that's the case. Okay.
Every single person knows that the That's a joke, by the >> It's
not. It might be like maybe
7 to 10 lbs above what she expected, right? And then she immediately
makes the comment like, "Well, my measurements are the >> I
just think everybody had that moment where they go to the doctor
and it like the doctor's office scale is off from yours or something,
right?
I I have that where I like go to the doctor's office and it's
like I've not gained weight or anything, but I know that the
scale there is going to be like calibrated differently than my
home scale going to be accurate, right?
And so I suggested
first of all, let's be honest here, that is not knowable. That
is cope.
Maybe it is, maybe it isn't. I have no idea. >> Oh, also
give me two seconds. I'm just going to grab some water. I'll
be right back. But like I don't know why we're making exclamatory
statements about things that we have no ability to verify in
that moment, right? But sure, whatever. Say what you want. But
what I said was, "Hey, maybe you should just track your macros
so you have an additional piece of information that you can reference,
right?" It's like, I feel like that's reasonable, right? It's
like, oh, you know, maybe it's hormonal and it's not about, you
know, any change in eating habits or maybe it's a change in eating
habits that you're not accounting for. But like if you you know
figure out by tracking for a little bit, you'll know. And you
know later on when I called her out on like you know like it
doesn't help when in the moment you just throw up like the the
the notion that oh my measurements are exactly the same. It's
like that's not like you don't got to tell me that. It's just
not like a a statement, you know, short of measuring that you
can really say.
>> All right, I'm back. >> And she goes, I know it's
true, though. And I go, fine, then measure yourself. And she
goes, wow, you're acting weird. It's like, okay, so it's a faith-based
approach to metrics. I see.
I I didn't realize. Sorry. Right. I didn't realize we'd gone.
>> Is she doing like metrics? Is that what you're Is she
trying to do metrics? I don't feel like she's trying to do
>> at all. Faith based on this. It's like, what the is
this, dude? Like, here's the thing, right? You tell me you're
not going to change the thing. That's fine. Just tell me I don't
care if I gain weight. I don't care.
Okay? But don't sit here and say, "Whoa,
why am I heavier than I remember?
At least my measurements are the same." when you haven't done
measurements. Like, what is that?
Like, why am I, you know, like what am I even supposed to do
there, you know? Well, I mean, look, I don't know. It could just
be that I don't know if she's worked out or if she's been riding
horses and so there's like, you know, um, development of leg
muscles over >> Oh, a couple people pointing out that obviously
if all of her clothes still fit then,
yeah, if all of her clothes still fit, then probably she's not,
you know, measuring differently. That seems kind of reasonable.
Although then I guess cos fitting is like subjective. They might
fit tighter. >> 10 pounds is not that much, right? >> Oh,
is he is he saying the amount it was off by?
That's that's such like a mean girl comment. Okay, listen listen.
10 lb isn't that much on a girl who's like what, 5'5?
Like 140 lb. 10 lbs is a lot, man. 10 lbs is a lot.
>> Yeah, I have no idea. But the >> I said 140. She's
probably like 115, right? Actually, I don't know why I said 140.
She's probably like 115 or some >> The point is, if you
are asserting that it is >> Wait, Amaranth, how tall is
Amaranth?
>> Yeah, how tall is Amaranth? I need to see how tall she
is. Amaranth's 5'4.
She looks like she's like a she's like a sturdier person though,
right? Like she's she's got like wider shoulders and she got
to be like 130, 140, you'd >> Unchanged.
Then why are you calling me out when I said then just measure
it? Like I don't understand the idea of like trying to pretend
that something is true just because you want it to be right.
I don't understand
But if you tell me that that is the the delusion that you want,
well then fine. >> Okay. Some dude spamming Hannah Rididgeway
wants you, Nick. >> I'm okay with that. chat, >> but
to me as a, you know, person who's trying to make sense of it
all, it doesn't really,
>> it doesn't really jive, you know? It doesn't really
jive. I don't know. I I just hate this uh thing that she does
where every time she's angry, she has to storm out of the house.
It's like, why the do we build a walled fortress to just leave
it every time
to prove a point?
What the [__] is that? Why? Why bother? Why not just
leave the gates the way they are? Leave the fences as high as
they were. It doesn't work if you become hyper predictable,
right? And you storm out every >> Bro, this is Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, she
typed. Well, I didn't see
>> I did not see it. So, this would be the first message
then. So, she would have just said, uh, all I asked for is you
to not try to manage my macros or body measurements. Got it.
Oh, here we go. My favorite
is in chat.
>> Yo, what the Bro, what?
Oh, he's not being truth. >> He's not being truthful, chat.
Sure. Is that why you shy away from debate and want things to
be cloaked in shadow?
>> Did you just say
my wife won't stop running from debates?
My wife is is My wife is totally gripping
in our relationship. She keeps running from debates. She won't
meet me in the arena of ideas. The marketplace of ideas.
Oh yeah, you alone get to pick the context. None of this narrating
is the right order or context of anything that's actually been
said is what Amaran says in the chat. Oh, I might need to move
myself so you guys can see it. Here, I'll go over here. I'll
go here.
Ka. Ka, don't make me. Ka place. Ka place. She's not listening.
Ka place.
Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Let me I'm going to go get the remote. I'm I'm going
to get the remote. Come over here.
H. She's not listening. She's not listening.
Last warning, Ka. Oh, there it is. There it is. I'm sorry. Had
to be done. Had to be done. Had to be done. There. Okay. She
back. He's back. She's in place. All right. But when it comes
to me, you get to tell me what I said as well. Do you not understand
that? Like if you get to tell me what I mean,
then none of your nitpicking of narrative has any value because
we're just observing it through the lens of
my feelings are valid. >> You see that Ethan clip where
they find out that Netanyahu actually also had a dog named Ka.
No, I can't imagine that's funny, but maybe you want to link
it. >> You know, bro, because you were making
>> says you wanted us to mute then secret unmute mid combo.
crazy remarks and yelling so loud that people could hear and
I wanted another record of events in case you said something
crazy. Dude, did you do you understand that we have staff downstairs?
You didn't close the door. You start screaming at the top of
your lungs and I'm just like, why why were we why were we yelling
so loud? I don't know what the you're trying to pull. It looks
bad. It sounds bad. And you can go downstairs and say anything
you want. That's why.
Bro, you literally looked me in the eye and said I said something
I didn't say. >> There's no justification. We have cameras.
She says >> we have cameras, not in that room. Did you
put a camera in that room? If so, yay. But I don't think we have
a camera in that room. Am I wrong? Hey, answer the question.
You said there's a camera in the bedroom. I don't think there
is. Is there? If there's not, then how the is it going to be
clear to anyone? You
>> uh What did somebody just ask if this was streamed live?
This was streamed live. Hold on. Oh, sorry you didn't ask that.
Jesus. >> Think, man. When you say that's like I'm like,
wait, that's not what happened.
Like, you have to understand something, okay?
When you start to bend the lines of objective reality, I don't
know what the do. The point is this, okay?
I just listen. I I don't have the clip on my streamable anymore,
so I have to go find it. But like I I really feel like Nick's
the last person who can talk about bending the lines on predictable
reality or or objective reality,
right? We remember what he said abuse was and we remember how
he reacted. Like he doesn't get to he doesn't get to define this.
He doesn't get to be the source of this for anybody anymore.
>> Did you start screaming for no reason on at the top
of your lungs?
Like why? Like why? We don't have a camera in the bedroom. That's
what I'm saying. Like like do and you realize what you were saying,
right? Do you realize what you were saying? You were >> a
second here. I'm trying to find
>> I'm trying to find really quickly the video on my hard
drive cuz I don't have it on my stream bowl anymore. >> That
I said you needed to dress. I have never said that. I have never
said that. That is not words that I have said. Firstly, I have
no idea what constitutes
just more revealing or what.
Like that is insane, you know? Like that's insane. You literally
said, "I told you to dress." I >> I am fed up with you
pulling me aside to >> You never said that, >> says
Amaran. >> Oh, you're fed up. Oh, you're fed up. Life has
just been too good for you in the last couple of months that
you know us talking is too much. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't tell you
do more egirl stuff. That was the third suggestion because we're
going down a list and the first two about Twitter ped you the
off even though it doesn't really require.
>> You literally tell me to do more egirl stuff and get
more Only Fans conversion >> much from you at all. It's
just if you want to do this, this is a better way to do it.
Bro, the fact remains and you won't answer this because you're
a coward.
>> Do you want to [__] keep doing this or not?
Or maybe you just want to keep doing it, but you don't want me
to keep doing it. Why don't you just say once and for all that
you don't want me to do anything for you, and I will stop and
we'll see how far that goes. I'm supposed to hop on a meeting
for you right now. Maybe we won't do that. Maybe we'll just say
them and then I won't pay
>> If you want to be difficult, maybe I'll stop paying
all of our employees. Maybe I'll just send everybody home. Maybe
I'll make our lives totally grind to a halt.
Wow.
You've told me I need to do more egirl stuff for months, many
times. >> Answer the question. Do you want me involved
or not?
Cuz I would love to just stop responding to everyone. Answer
the question. Say the word. The truth is you want me helping
you and you want me to help you do this thing. >> Scan
through these comments one more time really quickly. Uh, this
extreme option giving makes no sense. Is that the only thing?
Okay. >> Uh-huh. extreme option making. Bro, if you need
my help or if you want my help, then we can talk about how I
help, but we cannot not talk and have you throw me under the
bus every time you don't like it.
I'm okay with let's talk about what the boundaries are, but you
don't talk. And you're saying that me pulling you aside and saying
let's talk off stream is a issue. Bro, you have to understand,
okay, contextually, if we were here arguing when there's no one
here, it's fine.
But when we are upstairs, >> I don't believe that. I do
I do not believe that they're fine arguing off stream. That's
insane. >> And the staff is downstairs and you're yelling
at the top of your lungs and you're saying that I have never
said.
It is kind of scary for me to not have an independent record
of events.
It shouldn't be, right? But you created this feeling, right?
Cuz you have accused me of things I have not done many times
now. many times. >> I think
I mean he he's got like two options here, right? If if this is
okay. Oh, what did she say? Oh, yesterday wasn't the first time
she got told about Egirl stuff. Okay. If he really believes this,
if he really believes that she's just going to lie about him,
then and he thinks like that's going to be detrimental to his
life in some way that he should go,
right? It shouldn't be like, "Oh, I'm going to like stay and
keep yelling at you until you agree with me." Now, again, just
based on the actual record of what we've seen on stream when
we try to resolve something, like when he says, "Well, I need
an independent record cuz you lie all the time." Well, we've
only seen the lying go one way. We've never seen the lying from
Amaranth about him. We have seen him totally fabricate instances
with her. So, I I this smacks of like total bull to me. It it
like I smell bull. >> I have never gotten any reassurance
that you were going to stop that again. You literally looked
me in the face
and you told me that I told you to dress
and now you're trying to backtrack and say, "Well, you said I
needed to up conversions," which the only thing that can mean
is dress, which is insane because literally I said otherwise
Like when I said, "Hey, um, these things are down. Uh, next time
we do this thing, we should do it like this. And then we when
we do that thing, we should do it like that about Twitter.
It is nothing to do with you or
it is literally everything to do with let's strike while the
iron is hot on these other conversation threads.
Okay? It has nothing to do with posting pictures. It has nothing
to do with looking. Those were my lead two examples. You sh all
over me for that. I don't even know why. >> Former black
guy comes in and says, "I just got my butt ate to the stream."
Congratulations, buddy. I'm hope I'm hoping this stream made
it better for you, my friend. Very weird thing to put into the
chat. >> I still don't really know why. Like, I literally
brought to you information, then I gave you a recommendation,
and then you sh all over me and started yelling at me. So, I
mean, like, what the [__] am I supposed to do? Try
a different tact? The truth is, yesterday
when you asked me what it is I like to do, I could list five
things, but I stopped myself at one because I knew going any
further would cause a fight because you were already super super
adversive to the one that I mentioned that was so benign.
Okay,
happy to tell you, you know, dude, think about what that means.
Okay, just think about what that means in this context. He's
like basically like when I when I told you you're not attractive
enough, you're not doing enough. Like
like that's how she feels. I you freaked out about the thing
that's benign. Wait until you hear the other suggestions I had.
Just wait until you hear them. It's like I know exactly where
he's going to go there to try to drag his wife down. Like it
it would be it's not like difficult to understand what she feels
self-conscious about and to like do that, right? Like to to to
know what he's going to say next. And you just don't do that.
You you obviously avoid those things if you have any interest,
right? And you don't threaten those things ever. You never say,
"Oh, I could be so much. I could say the things that would really
Why? Why?
Why?"
But he does this all the time. He always threatens these things
all the >> But like I said, well, what about the scavenger
hunt?
You know, like like and you were already so aggressive about
that that I was just like, "Okay, well, this is not going anywhere."
>> Wait, what about the scavenger hunt?
Wait, how did they I forget. Oh, the fight at the scavenger hunt
was so insane. Do you remember that when he like couldn't get
over the fact that she got scared when he knocked on the window?
He was like looking for his wallet or something. He's looking
for something on the ground and he knocks on the window cuz she
won't answer. And she like starts crying and freaking out with
like a PTSD response. And that like blew up their entire week
for scavenger hunt. >> I don't know what the you're saying
cuz you're saying too many typos, buddy. >> Okay, that's
real though. I know how that feels. Okay, this guy is saying
too many insane things for me to keep track of. like way too
many. This chatter keeps saying like he is literally not being
coherent at all. He's like doing two-word responses to the things
I say. Yeah, I can't I can't understand that there's like a 10-second
delay on chat or something. Yeah, be coherent. God damn it. Okay,
so it seems like this [__] basically done. We're
basically done here. >> Oh, no. It's perfectly fine.
>> it's perfectly
>> Anyway, I just
I was going to Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Fine for her to
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. We might keep watching
for a second cuz >> Amaranth responds. You want the numbers
back? I used to dress like an eirl on stream. You act like that
rationalization is a crazy concept. As in if he talks about how
here's how we get the numbers back. Here's how we start winning
again, right? And it's always [__] Hold on. Going
to get my line up here. There we go. Okay. And it's always, oh,
we want to get back to where we were. He obviously she's going
to go Well, I guess before that was stuff, right? So, I guess
we'll go do that again. That's not a crazy rationalization. He
could say, "No, no, no. I don't think you have to do that. We
can go in a different direction." But unless there's like work
being done in a different direction, I don't think it's weird
for her to think that.
>> Remember when he claimed Ammo gave a hand job to the
Fresh and Fit producer? Yes. Very goofy, very goofy guy. >> But
my point is that there is a correct way to say it and there is
an incorrect way. And if you want, I I've always been open to
if you don't like the messaging, bro. The point is I I don't
care if you're rationalizing. If you want to rationalize, Kate,
you can ask me, "Is this what you mean?"
But like, for you to say, "I said XYZ" when I didn't say XYZ
is lying.
Do you see how unsettling that is in the context of the fact
that you've lied about me a lot in the past? Can you not see?
It doesn't seem like a lie. It seems like Hold on. It doesn't
seem like a lie at all.
It seems like she's literally saying this is how I rationalize
thinking that how that is a issue. You said I coerced you in
a contract. Ain't never happened. You said I made you do content.
Also never happened. Can you see how a third thing is kind of
like, well, bro, I think I want an independent recording of this.
Can you not see that? Or am I supposed to just walk around getting
my head blown off
by random strays that you send my way? I'll ask you again because
you're choosing to not engage with the question, which is parlor
course.
Can you not >> think you meant par for the course? It's
par for the course. Not parlor course, not part of the course,
but par for >> I see how when you start saying you said
this and I didn't say it. You see, you aren't even saying
when you say this, it makes me feel this way. That's fine. Okay?
If you said when you say this, it brings up these bad memories.
Okay? I can work with that. You cannot say you said these words
when I didn't say those words.
You can't mean or take something else that I said and say that
to you means this thing. So, I said this thing word for word.
You can't do that. >> He's not doing that. By the way,
everybody does that. Literally, everybody does that, right? That's
what language is. Is you basically take somebody's like set of
symbols they they they put out into the world towards you. You
understand them, and then you translate them based on the context
you're currently in, and you derive the meaning of the words
they just said, right? And he's basically like, "Oh, the normal
human process." He he can feel like he's not being understood,
that's reasonable. But to say she's lying, she's she said repeatedly,
"This is what I think you said. This is how I made this inference."
She's saying she's inferring. She's not lying. She's literally
telling you she's inferring this.
Do you understand that?
That is just lying.
You can use your words and say, "When you say this, I feel this
way." Perfectly fine.
But your feelings do not change the fabric of I >> That
That's what she does. That's that's what she did here. That's
that's literally what's happening.
no matter how much you want them to. Reality is reality. Fact
is fact. What happened is what happened. You don't get to quote
something because you feel it's
The hell does that even mean? It's not facts over feelings.
But it's feelings cannot change facts. >> It doesn't need
to be facts over feelings. It can be both. But you have to express
that. You have to say this makes me feel bad. Can we say it this
other way or can we avoid saying it like that? It's not about
one over the other. It's the two should not intersect
and be muddled.
It is feeling.
It is you know your emotional. >> He's just he just say
intermod >> sentiment or it is fact and it's you know actually
something that happened. Bro, are you saying that you >> Oh,
she came back. She came back. She came back. I didn't say you
said it. I told you what what you I told you what you actually
said and what I'm doing about it that yields those results.
>> Say to me
that I said you needed to dress more. I literally said, "Hey,
the the thing that set this off was me saying, "Hey, you dressing
this way in front of staff makes me uncomfortable." And then
you flip out and start yelling at the top of your lungs.
Okay. You start yelling at the top of your lungs and you go,
"You asked me to dress this way. You said for me to dress."
And I was like, "What? I have never ever
picked out your clothing or ever ever asked you to dressier
or more revealing or whatever the word is. I don't care what
the word is. The none of that has
I will say though that I have many times asked you to dress less
and this today was one of them. >> That's uh
that's kind of a wild thing to throw out into the world to be
honest with you. I
Why are his eyes so wet? Well, I think I don't know. His eyes
are bloodshot. It's probably cuz he's like barely functioning.
Is Dude, it's 23 hours into his stream. He must be exhausted.
How the [__] can I say A and you get Z? You're not
being honest. I have said the opposite
thing that you have attributed to me. Okay? Literally, dude,
at times I have said, "Hey, I think this is too much for
And you ignore me every time. You ignore me every time, you know.
No, bro. Oh, okay. Now you're going to you're going to mince
it and say, "Oh, all you're talking about is conversions, bro."
>> Uh, she's she says, "I said I you wanted me to get more."
Dude, can they just come together? >> You didn't say that,
buddy.
But I'm glad you at least see the need to lie about what you
actually said because at least that shows me you know that what
is what is this man? >> You did not just say
that. You said that I asked you to dress more.
You said that.
Okay. Maybe you said the other thing as well, but bro, between
those two messages, I'm going to see the one that's just a bold
lie. You you have to understand. Okay.
Words. >> All right. I don't know if I I don't know. have
meaning. >> I'm like interested in doing more, but I >> just
because you >> I'm I'm tapping I'm just about tapping >> watching
your stream. Did you just retcon
what actually happened? There's streams of us where you said
you're not going to go again
and that's the first time I'm hearing it is watching your stream.
It's very simple. I my I feel like my line is very simple. It's
we can talk about anything or we can not talk about anything.
All that is is communication,
right? You want to avoid a subject right now? Fine. Tell me when
we can talk about it. If the answer is never, then tell me that's
the answer because I can navigate around a never. I can navigate
uh not right now.
>> I cannot navigate you just >> I don't know, man.
>> Why is he talking to her through the stream instead
of in person? Uh cuz they already had an argument in person.
Didn't go well. >> Right. You shouldn't say later when
you mean never. Right.
Okay, our our next options for content. Okay, we've got a couple
and oh, I've not shilled. God damn it. Hold on. I haven't shilled
at all. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead, throw a couple
bucks in the pot to get more time on the stream. I think we are
I don't even know where we are in terms of monetization today.
Four. So, we're six. No, we're eight subs away from two more
hours. We need those two more hours because there's a couple
things I want to get to. The next piece I want to get to, okay,
I think the next thing we're going to do is I'm being told that
they had a ColorGate segment on Live and Learn and I'm very excited
to see how that will break down given okay given how invested
Hutch is in it and given how much I assume Pisco doesn't give
a Okay, I don't know where I or anyone else shakes out in this,
but I got to assume like this doesn't mean anything. And I got
to also believe that Hutch is like, "No, Hassan is done for real
this time. He's totally cooked. It's over for Hassan."
So, that's probably where we're going to go next, guys. Uh, eight
subs. You can sub on kick. You can uh give Twitch primes. You
can donate through either of the TTS links. Okay. Exclamation
point. Donate in the chat is for the TTS links. All right. There's
Streamlabs. There's Kickbot. You can donate through either one.
Add more time to the stream. Let's uh let's continue.
Only Hutch would care. I don't know. I I could see soy pill caring